the outstanding arsenal
that has been reshaped for jeff hoffman
essentially has five different pitches
now but the biggest one
the return of the slider fly ball hit in
the air and pretty deep left center
field going back on it since el he's at
the warning track he'll reach up just in
front of the reds bullpen to make the
catch
now as the sun peeks through the clouds
josh van meter
payoff swing into this that was in the
zone
and van meter bends the knee starting
pitcher for the d-backs is taylor
widener 26-year-old right-hander
who has inserted himself into the
rotation by impressing the coaches all
spring and now bob it seems like he's
here to stay
jesse winker stands in to lead things
off for the reds
and winker unloads to left field peralta
looks
up bye bye baseball jesse winker
connects
a lead off big fly and the reds claim a
one-nothing lead
we talked about jesse winker and his
aggressiveness early
in the count we saw a good pitch by
widener that first pitch fastball down
and then that one got a little too much
of the plate and jesse winker has been
outstanding this year super aggressive
and hitting the ball
extremely well to all parts of the field
base hit for josh rojas
second hit for the diamondbacks and
here's the pitcher whitener
right back to the mound and often throws
it away
rohan stays put at second hammond back
caught a break there that should have
been a double play
ball bunning hard right back to the
mound hoffman in good position to throw
but just air mails it to suarez at
second base josh rojas is safe there
taylor widener safe on first i would
assume an e1 but
we'll see and here's the lead off hitter
pavon smith
basketball punch the other way and
that's fair down the line
here comes rojas to tie the ball game
they'll stop wider it's an hour behind
double for pavon smith in a 1-1 ball
game
the number two hole hitter today wyatt
mathison
not a fastball hits it out to right
center
denzel collects it here comes widener
rbi for matheson
pavon smith's at third and it's two to
one diamondbacks the lead all single
and here is winker
stupid bat i hate this bat second
strikeout for taylor
he's gonna run out of bats in that ritz
dugout taylor widener back to work
against the heart of the cincinnati
order
suarez chops one backhanded by matheson
want to play
get him what a play by wyatt matheson
over there
backhanding that one coming way off the
bank at first and widener hustles over
and they get suarez
young right-hander goes to work against
kyle farmer
strike three on a slider five strikeouts
for taylor widener
mark payton is going to come off the
bench to pinch hit here for cincinnati
taylor widener now has three consecutive
strikeouts and six for the bowl game
well here's jesse winker taylor widener
strikes out the side
that's four in a row and seven in the
ball game
2-1 diamondback here's david peralta
he's holding it first and david gets a
fastball and drives it to right center
and that's gone david peralta
gets one up in the air a two-run home
run and it's 4-1 diamondbacks
david was just saying the other day his
timing's been off he's not hitting line
drive the way he usually does
too many balls on the ground but that
one gets up and
over the fence in right center threads
are going to rally this is the exact
part of the order you want to see it
from
two three and four and he shoots this
one to left field
and that's gone home run nick
castellanos his first game back well he
talked about how he wanted to be
considered
an elite hitter down an in pitch not a
bad pitch by widener
but a really good swing by nick
castellanos
shift is on for suarez oh and he does
launches to deep left center field home
run
hey eugenio suarez targay
well you know it's coming you don't just
hit 49 home runs and then all of a
sudden forget how to hit
and you can see a little extra
jubilation from henny
man he destroyed that baseball watch the
fan
go after the suarez homer oh no
oh man and the batter is kyle firmer
chases another slider out there
bukowskis comes in gets two outs to win
the inning
but the reds get two home runs they tie
it at fours a couple of bases on balls
open up the inning why had matheson now
we'll bet
it's a low fast ball and knocks it into
left field
here comes rojas here's the throw and
it's not in time
wyatt mathis that makes it five for
diamondbacks
and they're loaded for the freight train
with one out
punches it the other way and that one is
a base hit
andrew young scores here comes matheson
and he is in there
a two-run knock for david peralta
and it's 7-4 d-bags and they are loaded
with one out for eduardo escobar
he walked in a run doolittle has
walked three of the six he's faced nick
heath is home and it's eight to four
josh rojas began the inning with a walk
one two
swing and a miss a spin and a sigh of
relief from doolittle
diamondbacks played four double up the
reds stand up double begins the home
seven
now jesse winker who launched to center
field
nick heath home run jesse winker
straight away center back to back extra
base hits for the reds and they get a
couple back it's 8-6
what else can you say the man can just
flat out hit another ball barrel
joey bottle has singled and scored
payoff
in the air pretty deep left center field
joey vano joins the home run parade five
big flies for the raids today
and a one run game really like this
version of joey votto and i think he
know he got that ball he knew he got
that ball right there you can see the
dismount
each of the first four hitters in this
reds lineup of homert including suarez
who homer to his last time
up yeah
well they got this thing surrounded and
rojas
comes flying in from right and that's
out number two
nice sliding catch by josh rojas calling
for it
and catching jonathan india has not yet
gone deep
in the bigs guys get their arms extended
and the ball travels and that one is
gone the first career home run for
jonathan india and fitting that helmet
flew
as soon as he rounded first the flow
show
is on and the reds have tied the game
a little silent treatment going on in
the bullpen and the dugout
for the rookie now they're
congratulating him peralta's at second
as the go ahead run
and so cabrera will take the at-bat 1-2
swing into this lucas sims does the job
retires the two that he faces
it'll be the heart of the order well
here's the highly anticipated caleb
smith
max schrock matchup caleb smith two
strikeouts and a one
two three ninth inning and we will play
extra baseball
in cincinnati caprera who made the final
out in the ninth
will start the tenth at second base and
the battery will be josh rohan
up the middle and throw there comes
cabrera and as drobol is in there
josh rojas makes it nine to eight one
run already in
and now they're loaded for matheson
swing and a miss
nice bounce back right there two down
for peralta who's knocked in four today
peralta sends it to center and that one
gets behind naquin
and everybody's gonna come on in it gets
all the way to the wall
yeah peralta's at third three runs are
home
and the diving backs have a 12 to eight
lead in front of tyler naquin
he actually took a horrible line after
that ball it gets by him all the way to
the wall
that is a triple for peralta and his
fifth
base hit he has knocked in seven runs
carson kelly carson kelly
tack one on baby
so carson joins the home run parade
that's just the second for the
diamondbacks the fourth of the year
attaboy tucker barnhart is walked he was
robbed on a line drive to right
barnhart pulls it on the ground that's
through into right field for a base hit
heading to third and getting the wave
home is shrock he will score easily
an rbi single for tucker barnhart makes
it 14-9
winker walks base is loaded 0-2
left field gets down base hit
one run scores naquin second run
scores stevenson crosses
it's a three-run game and the tying run
will bat and it's joey bottom
[Applause]
got him and the diamondbacks hang on and
win it 14-11 in 10 innings they get
their first series sweep in cincinnati
since 2015